from the foreign policy establishment to
third wave feminists fake news explodes
like a North Korean new queen fact from
fiction
then Eric's wall wells parody of a
presidential campaign is running out of
money surprise surprise and president
Trump takes the presidential reality TV
show to Japan I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the greatest radio interview that has
ever been conducted in the history of
the world took place at the end of last
week this is with the feminist author
Naomi Wolf promoting her new book on BBC
three radio and during this interview
feminism collapsed entirely it's so
great we will listen to the clip but
first we can all agree on at least one
thing that we need a little bit more
sleep getting a great night's sleep is
now easier and more affordable than you
think
I was at my friend's wedding over the
weekend I had to sleep in a hotel room I
had to sleep on not Boland branch sheets
I barely slept a wink thankfully I got
home last night and I got to cuddle up
on my bowl and branch if you want a
better sleep you just need to change
your sheets which is why you should
check out Boland branch everything they
make from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton means they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time they feel so what it
actually feels like is just staying at a
luxury hotel I've gotten to stay at a
few luxury hotels over the years and it
feels categorically different because
the sheets they have are super nice so
now I looked into buying the sheets
myself you to buy these luxury sheets
usually costs about $1,000 in the store
thankfully with Boleyn branch there are
only a couple hundred bucks to get
five-star luxury every single night and
if you're like me you know you're gonna
be on those sheets for 18 19 hours a day
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund but you won't want to
send them back I'm telling you I now
give these out as gifts wedding gifts
housewarming gifts they're so great no
risk no reason not to try to get started
right now you are gonna get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at Boleyn
branch com promo code Michel mi CH AE L
make sure you spell it right if you want
50 bucks off go to ball and branch comm
50 bucks off your first set of sheets Bo
ll and branch comm promo code Michael mi
CH AE L Boland branch comm promo code
Michael even better after I got my
lovely sleep on my bowline branch sheets
I wake up and I get to play this
interview with Naomi Wolf for those of
you who don't know Naomi Wolf she is
possibly the leading feminist author in
the world and she has been a preeminent
feminist for at least two decades now
she was an advisor to Bill Clinton so
when Bill Clinton had all of his girl
troubles in the 90s he brought in Naomi
Wolf to shore up support among women
Al Gore hired her to support his
campaign in 2000 she she literally
helped to launch the third wave of
feminism with her book the beauty myth
she's just been a major figure and she
collapsed on the radio the other day I
have to say a lot of conservatives were
really spiking the football on this and
we're just so happy because they hate
Naomi Wolf
I sort of like Naomi wolf and I've
always liked her
not because she's terribly insightful
not because she is honest as you'll see
in this interview as she gets the facts
very very wrong but I've always felt
that Naomi Wolf would at least
honestly follow her arguments to their
logical conclusions so even if she
started with false premises she would at
least take them all the way to the
conclusion in 1995 writing in The New
Republic she wrote an essay about
abortion and she said quote abortion
should be legal it is sometimes even
necessary sometimes the mother must be
able to decide that the fetus in its
full humanity must die this shocked
obviously the pro-life movement and it
shocked
abortion supporters as well it shocked
the pro-life movement because we
couldn't believe how honest she was she
said yes the fetus is a baby it's fully
human it's fully alive and we have to
kill it in order for women to be equal
it's an appalling statement but it's
honest the pro-abortion movement was
horrified by this because they're
basically saying don't be so honest
don't let the cat out of the bag you
have to deny that the baby is a baby you
have to deny that the baby is alive and
she didn't she said no if we want
abortion if the argument for abortion is
that men and women need to be equal men
don't get pregnant well I guess these
days they do get pregnant but this was
this was back in the old timey days
before men could be women and women
could be men men can't get pregnant
women
and so the only way to have true gender
equality is to allow mothers to kill
their babies that was the argument
that's that's really the only coherent
argument for abortion I've ever heard
and she at least advanced that so I
always gave her credit for that still
even if she's following arguments
honestly if the premises are false then
the argument is going to be false as
well and the the premise of her new book
was just eviscerated live on the air she
was doing this interview on BBC Radio 3
and she realized that the the thesis of
her book which is called outrages sex
censorship and the criminalization of
love is based on a lie this is a
slightly lengthy segment it is worth
every second it is worth every single
word give it a listen
record it I was really surprised by this
and I looked it up death recorded is
that is what in I think most of these
cases that you've er you've identified
as executions it doesn't mean that he
was executed it was a category that was
created in 1823 that allowed judges to
abstain from pronouncing a sentence of
death on any capital convict whom they
considered to be a fit subject for
pardon I don't think any of the
executions you've identified here
actually happened well that's a really
important thing to investigate what is
your what is your understanding of well
what deaths recorded means death
recorded this is also from I've just
read you the definition of it they're
from the Old Bailey website but I've got
here a newspaper report about Thomas
silver and also something from from the
prison records that showed the date of
his discharge the prisoner was found
guilty and sentence of death was
recorded yeah recommended the prisoner
to mercy on account of his youth see I
think this I think this is a kind of
when I found this I didn't really know
what to do with it because I think it is
I think it's quite a big problem with
your argument although it's the nature
of the offence here
Thomas Silva committed an indecent
assault on a six-year-old boy stop it
stop it she is already dead it starve it
don't go it's so totally devastating it
is almost painful to listen to that
Oh clip so she says the premise of her
book is that gay men were executed for
consensual sex in the UK in the 19th
century early 20th century and it's this
awful oppression and see it's really
been happening over time the reason that
she concluded that is because in cases
of sodomy the punishment was death
recorded and so Naomi Wolf apparently
ignorant of the English jurisprudential
tradition just assumed that meant that
the person had been executed somehow
they hadn't death recorded was just a
way for the judge to say okay you've
been sentenced to death for your crime
your death is now recorded you're okay
you get out of jail it was a way to give
leniency to people and also in so
obviously this is an egregious error if
you're gonna write a book with the
premise that gay men were executed in
the United Kingdom you need to know what
these terms mean you need to be able to
prove that point but okay I mean maybe
some of us also ignorant of English
jurisprudence maybe we would have fallen
for that too then he goes on with a
knockout punch at the end he says also
it's not that these were cases of
consensual sex between adult gay men
this guy that you're talking about raped
a six-year-old boy and then he goes on
and points out in so many of the other
cases
she is observing we're talking about not
just statutory rape you're talking about
a forcible rape between adults
none of these cases appear to have been
consensual at least the ones that this
interviewer looked into and what does
Naomi Wolf get to say she can say oh
well yes I suppose we should look into
that what does this word mean I mean it
just totally collapses the problem with
feminism is not that feminists are bad
people
the problem with feminism is not that
they know their arguments necessarily go
completely off the rails
the problem with feminism is that it's
based on lies such as this the problem
with gender theory is it's based on lies
is this I mean just demonstrable
historical untruths and so what what do
they do they have to rewrite the past I
mean you hear this even third wave
feminists now will say that until 1965
women were brutally horribly oppressed
in this country this is this is one of
the claims right before second wave
feminism women were horribly oppressed
everything was terrible then with the
rise of second wave feminism women's
station and life gradually increased
they got more political rights more
opportunities in the workplace more
social privileges and therefore now
everything's great
the problem with that narrative that
women had it terrible before the sixties
and now it's really great is that study
after study shows women have become less
happy specifically since that time
specifically since the rise of second
wave feminism women have become less
happy in both absolute terms and in
relative terms relative to men's
happiness
based on lies these these gender Theory
ideas that come around or based on the
lie that men can be women and women can
be men and so they make arguments from
those premises of which bathrooms you
should use what hormones you should
inject what clothing you should wear the
the arguments I suppose sort of make
sense except they're based on a lie and
so what Naomi Wolf is demonstrating here
and what a lot of these these radicals
do is they have to change the past they
have to erase the past they have to say
that gay men were executed for
consensual sex as a widespread epidemic
in the United Kingdom in the past it
didn't happen we can look into the
historical record and show that it
didn't but by controlling the past you
control the future by erasing the past
you control the future that's why the
radical left wants to tear down
monuments rename buildings rename
memorials by controlling the past you
control the future this is why Oliver
Stone makes a movie about the
assassination of JFK in which JFK is not
killed by a communist as actually
happened and as we know happened but
he's killed by a bunch of Republicans or
the military-industrial complex or the
CIA or whatever this is why Adam McKay
needs to make a movie about Dick Cheney
in which Dick Cheney does a number of
awful
things that we know for a fact he didn't
do in Adam McKay's movie and Vice Dick
Cheney leaks the identity of this CIA
operative Valerie Plame we know that
didn't happen
we know who leaked her identity we know
it was Richard Armitage but it doesn't
matter by controlling the past by
rewriting the past you get to control
the future and the this is happening in
feminism as well so what on earth can
Naomi Wolf do now
the thesis of her book proven incorrect
on air we'll see which way she can take
it because this is the question that
fake news has to deal with everywhere
the first rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer so you probably
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere including
myself ring helps you stay connected to
your home anywhere in the world so if
there is a package delivery or surprise
visitor you will get an alert you'll be
able to see hear and speak to them all
from your phone now the I suppose the
really good thing about ring is that it
keeps you safe you can be at your office
you can be in your bedroom you can be on
a beach somewhere and if someone comes
up to your door you can talk to them
it's uploaded to the cloud so even if
the robber steals your ring doorbell you
can still have the video and try to go
get him this happened to our senior
producer the other night a three a.m. a
couple of druggie weirdos showed up at
his house trying to see if anyone's home
he talked to them through his ring
doorbell they scampered away so that's I
guess the really good aspect of ring the
thing I like about it is it makes me
feel like I'm living in the future it
makes me feel like I'm in The Jetsons or
something I mean it's just unbelievable
technology that makes you feel safer
it's very convenient it's it's super
cool and it's available at an
extraordinarily reasonable inexpensive
price as a listener you have a special
offer right now in a ring starter kit
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
build a ring of security around your
home go to ring.com slash Knolls k no w
l es that is ring.com slash Knowles do
it now get a great deal so what can
Naomi Wolf do now her book falls apart
live on the air she handled this as best
as she could she came out and she said
oh I'll have to look into that or oh yes
okay this merits further investigation
so
what can she do she can either double
down she can go back obviously they're
gonna have to indefinitely push the
release of this book she can double down
she can find one case somewhere where a
consent consent xual gay guys were
killed for for being gay if she can find
that I don't even know that that exists
or more likely she can say okay they
weren't killed for being gay and having
gay sex but they were killed or rather
they did suffer political consequences
they were imprisoned they were they lost
their jobs they this that and really
this is just as bad as capital
punishment so really if you really think
about it actually really the thesis of
my book is correct and she can try to
salvage this book I mean it's it would
be a little pathetic but you could try
to do it now the other thing she can do
is admit that she was wrong this is the
hardest thing for people to do
especially political activists
especially people with a highly defined
ideology the best thing that they can do
is admit that they were wrong you know
the old conservative columnist the late
great Charles Krauthammer
was a dyed-in-the-wool liberal when he
was a young man he was a speechwriter
for the Democrat presidential candidate
Walter Mondale and then he became one of
the leading figures during the trumpet
during the Reagan administration and
later during the Bush to administration
he was a major conservative figure how I
I got to ask him this question well he
was alive and he said that he realized
that the policies that he had supported
the liberal policies actually hurt the
people that they were intended to help
he came to the same conclusion as Daniel
Patrick Moynihan Pat Moynihan a a
Democrat wrote the Moynihan report on
the consequences of all of those Great
Society welfare programs he realized
they were hurting the people they were
intended to help he changed his mind
this is a liberating experience when you
can change your mind I have changed my
mind on a number of topics throughout
the years I am sure I thought a lot of
stupid things about politics when I was
13 or 14 years old and then over time I
changed my mind and it's great I highly
recommend that you do it I used
support abortion abortions been in the
news a lot the last couple weeks I
thought abortion was just fine and dandy
III thought it was perfectly right it
would give women equality it was a
perfectly fine policy and then I
investigated it I read about abortion I
read about the realities of abortion I
had a conversation with a female
bioethicists when I was a student fellow
in DC and she made better arguments than
I did she told me things about abortion
that I didn't know and then I changed my
mind
and I'm glad I did because my old
opinion was incorrect and now my opinion
is correct the more the more I learn
about abortion the the more wrong I
realized that I was the trouble with
ideology and being so committed to
ideology is it makes you look ridiculous
and it traps you in to very narrow
thinking when you could admit that you
are wrong that is an act of humility it
is an act of wisdom and it is an act of
liberation we will see how Naomi Wolf
handles it she's always been one of the
better feminists I thought which is sort
of damning with faint praise so like the
the healthiest poison but she's always
been a little better than some of the
others shrieking ones so we'll see how
she handles it I hope she comes out and
says wow I was wrong I hope she goes out
and writes the opposite of this book it
says look people weren't oppressed for
their sexual preferences look people
weren't really victimized to the degree
that I thought they were
what a great thing I've learned
something about my cultural history and
that it makes me like my history moral
it makes me like my civilization more I
hope she writes that book not holding my
breath but it would that would be a true
breath of fresh air especially in a
highly partisan and ideological time
such as we are in but the fake news of
the weekend was not limited to feminism
there was also major fake news that came
out of the foreign policy establishment
you had this guy Ian Bremmer
if you haven't heard of Ian Bremmer he
he is the real deal this is a major
establishment figure in foreign policy
he's a political scientist he is a
professor at NYU he's the founder of the
Eurasia group
he's a talking head he'll go on
television a lot he writes for Time
magazine
this is not just some two-bit tweeter or
political pundit or something this guy
has credibility or had credibility in
foreign policy and he sent out a tweet
while President Trump was in Tokyo and
this is the whole text of the tweet
quote President Trump in Tokyo Kim
jong-un is smarter and would make a
better president than sleepy Joe Biden
and half people started retweeting as
thousands of retweets someone responded
and said that cannot be a real quote and
Bremer responded to her and said it's
plausible okay now you and I know this
is not plausible anybody who has not
been totally deranged by the Trump
administration who has not been become
this totally reactionary maniac who
believes that Trump is a secret
SuperDuper KGB Nazi spy trade or
whatever realizes that is not plausible
the president Trump says a lot of
colorful things but he would not go out
and say Kim jong-un is smarter and would
make a better president than Joe Biden
it's this quote is only plausible to
people who have an unrealistically
negative view of Trump he would look
Trump would say he actually has said a
lot of things about Joe Biden and about
Kim jong-un and about Kobe but come
jong-un and Joe Biden but he wouldn't
say that there's no way that the
president would endorse a North Korean
dictator for president / Joe Biden right
however among people who have an
unrealistically negative view of the
president they all believed they showed
themselves to be gullible fools Anna
Navarro who is a fake Republican she
goes on television and pretends to be a
Republican even though she is not I
don't remember the last time she did
anything that in any way aided any
Republican she came out and tweeted
quote she retweeted Bremer and she said
don't shrug your shoulders don't get
used to this insanity the President of
the United States praising a cruel
dictator who violates human rights
threatens nuclear attacks oppresses his
people and kills political opponents
quotes care capital letters is not
freaking normal
ana Navarro's not kidding around
Zach Pet con us who is a former senior
advisor to Hillary Clinton former senior
advisor to the Democrat National
Committee he tweeted out same thing same
Ian Bremmer quote the President of the
United States is not in control of his
faculties hashtag 25th amendment
suggesting we need to remove the
president from office because of the
quote that he and Bremer attributed to
him then Bremer came out and he admitted
the quote is completely ridiculous he
said that this was a Bremer's
explanation of it this is objectively a
completely ludicrous quote and yet kind
of plausible especially on Twitter where
people automatically support whatever
political position they have that's the
point so so what Bremer is saying is see
I got all of you I was exposing how
gullible you are this isn't a hoax this
is just an experiment this is just a
sort of art piece to show you how
gullible all of you are and also to show
you how President Trump says outrageous
things so that when he says something
that is even beyond the pale for
president Trump you sort of believe it
especially if you already don't like
President Trump that's that was Bremer
spin on this because he got a huge
negative reaction people rightly pointed
out that he spread fake news the
definition of rape fake news with the
President Trump then came out and
tweeted about it he said he and Bremer
now admits that he made up a completely
ludicrous quote attributing it to me
this is what's going on in the age of
fake news people think they can say
anything and get away with it really the
libel laws should be changed to hold
fake news media accountable I won't get
into the libel law discussion now that
will take us an hour probably
but Trump goes out and he says this this
is fake news look what he did it got
thousands and thousands of retweets
before he finally admitted that it
wasn't true and and Bremer now has since
apologized he said my tweet yesterday
about Trump referring Kim jong-un to
Biden as president was meant to ingest
the president quoted me as saying it was
completely ridiculous I should have been
clearer my apologies everybody is angry
at Ian Bremmer for this fake news the
right is angry because
it it he was trying to make Donald Trump
look crazy and unpatriotic and a lot of
people thousands and thousands of people
retweeted this before he came out and
admitted it was fake the left is angry
with Ian Bremmer because it makes them
look stupid and a little bit crazy which
isn't a surprise to any of us but
obviously he just made them look like
gullible fools so what about Ian
Bremer's excuses what about his excuse
that he was just showing us one how
outrageous Trump can be to have gullible
we are all all are on Twitter three the
the integrity of the news media and how
the integrity has been diminished how
the credibility has been diminished how
we don't check anything anymore how we
don't fact-check out we don't look into
things for ourselves does he have a
point yes totally he totally has a point
you should never run with something
because you saw a tweet about it you
should never quote anybody this one I
see all the time on the Internet
you'll see a picture of somebody and
then it quote next to them the famous
version of this is a picture of Abraham
Lincoln and it says don't believe
everything you read just because you saw
it on the Internet Abraham Lincoln this
is obviously mocking what people do
which is they'll read a quote they'll
see it next to a person's name and
they'll just assume it's true I I
investigate every single quote that I
put on this show or I put in writing or
that I read on the Internet
95% of the time the quotes that you read
on the Internet attributed to historical
figures or false they never said them
almost 100 percent of the time it's not
a scientific number I'm just telling you
from experience it virtually every quote
you read attributed to Winston Churchill
or George Washington or Thomas Jefferson
or Abraham Lincoln is just not true
and so when you see a quote on the
internet especially one that seems a
little ridiculous you should look it up
Remer to write about that is he write
that the president says outrageous
things yes he does
president Trump says outrageous things
and his critics Trump's critics in
particular don't know where the line of
plausibility is Trump could go out and
say oh Kim is a really nice guy or he
could say yeah Joe Biden's an idiot and
we and we would all assume that that is
totally plausible
it is not plausible that Donald Trump
would go out and say I think Kim jong-un
would make a great president of the
United States compared to Joe Biden
that's that is just too ludicrous Bremer
is also right that Twitter is
fundamentally performative Twitter is
not about conversation it is not about
exchange of ideas it is performative its
performative in the way that a
presidential debate is not about
conversation or exchanging ideas
it's about scoring points and showing
your audience that your opinion is
correct and the other guy's opinion is
wrong that is what Twitter is for people
have Twitter audiences those audience
are waiting for the people they're
following and we are waiting for the
people that we're following to say
things and to score points and to show
that the opinions that we all share are
more correct than the opinions that we
all oppose people don't really fact
check particularly the left people don't
use common sense particularly the left
because the left doesn't have a whole
lot of common sense
so should in Bremer have posted that
since it had it did have a lot of value
in that tweet and I really like it
because it's hilarious to show how
gullible the left is should he have
posted it no he shouldn't have we'll get
to why in a second we'll get to what
President Trump actually said about Kim
jong-un and Joe Biden which is almost as
outrageous not quite but it's almost as
outrageous pretty funny a lot of people
are upset about it and we'll get to
Eric's wall well but first got to go to
Daley wire.com ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the and reclaim ensure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh
show you get to ask questions of the
mailbag coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage coming up today
get ready for backstage you get another
Kingdom you've got so much stuff you get
the leftist here's tumblr oh that's
really good that is really good three
major political models are predicting
the president Trump is going to win in
2020 and the New York Times had to admit
it over the weekend
you're gonna need the tumbler but before
that look we're pretty early in the 2020
race you're already seeing the
front-runner hiding from everybody in
the race you're already seeing the New
York Times admit that they might not win
get the tumbler or you could drown go to
Daley wire.com we'll be right back
so in Bremer's tweet has a point it
shows that people on Twitter are too
gullible it shows that the president set
does say some outrageous things it shows
that the media are undignified and
usually spread fake news so it does have
a point he still shouldn't have tweeted
it why because he has a reputation and
it's not just him we all have
reputations but Ian Bremmer is a
recognizable name he has a little blue
checkmark
he goes to lunches at the Council on
Foreign Relations this is a real guy and
he is risking he is he is tarnishing his
reputation and his credibility by
engaging in this little joke or hoax or
experiment or art piece or whatever you
want to call it or whatever he wants to
call it that is fake news he did it he
shouldn't do it I get the point that
he's trying to make but he's making that
point at the expense of his credibility
the mainstream media have lost all of
their credibility over the last three
years too so I guess maybe that's not a
terrible thing that's the fake news
about Trump and Kim and Joe Biden the
real news is pretty out there as well
but the real news actually is a news
story President Trump during a press
conference in Japan was asked about a
quote from Kim jong-un where Kim jong-un
criticized Joe Biden and called him an
idiot
here is how President Trump responded to
this question well Kim jong-un made a
statement that Joe Biden is a low IQ
individual he probably is based on his
record I think I agree with him on that
but at the same time my people think it
could have been a violation as you know
I view it differently I view it as a man
perhaps he wants to get attention and
perhaps not who knows it doesn't matter
all I know is that there have been no
nuclear tests they've been no ballistic
missiles going out there have been no
long-range missiles going out and I
think that someday we'll have a deal
okay so I just can't help myself when I
heard this clip for the first time I
burst out laughing
mr. president kim jonghwan called joe
biden an idiot well listen he called Joe
Biden a low IQ individual judging from
the evidence this is probably correct
however and then he goes on I just burst
out laughing what should he have done
here for the people on the left and the
right who were criticizing him for this
response and saying it's undignified and
saying it's not nice to say mean things
about fellow politicians overseas and
saying that's all I get it
what was he supposed to do he was asked
if he agrees with Kim jong-un he was
asked if he was but he was asked about
this comment from Kim jong-un that Biden
is an idiot this is a trap right because
as a rule if you are agreeing with Kim
jong-un you're doing something wrong
you'd know no American politician wants
to be put in the position where he has
to agree with Kim jong-un so if he
agrees with Kim jong-un he looks awful
if he disagrees with Kim jong-un he
looks like a liar and a hack because
President Trump has pointed out that Joe
Biden is an idiot for years and years at
this point so you have Donald Trump says
Joe Biden's an idiot then Kim jong-un
says Joe Biden's an idiot then a
reporter says do you agree with Kim
jong-un that Joe Biden's an idiot
Trump has to say yeah of course I do
I've been saying it since way before Kim
jong-un was saying that Joe Biden's an
idiot also Joe Biden is an idiot little
bit of a side note but Joe Biden had
terrible academic records this is
actually the reason that he had to drop
out of the 1988 race because he
plagiarized a speech and because he lied
about his academic record he said he did
well in his law school class he actually
was number 76 out of 85 in his law
school class so just as an objective
matter the Joe Biden probably is a low
IQ individual still the the question is
should he have agreed with Kim jong-un
on this point especially overseas on top
of all of this President Trump as he
just said as you heard him say thinks
that he is going to get a deal with
North Korea a lot of people are highly
skeptical that he's
to deal with North Korea but he thinks
he is and he thinks that the way to get
a deal is not to antagonize Kim so I'm
not saying this is right I'm not saying
this is moral I'm not even saying it's
likely to work I'm just saying this is
the strategy Trump comes at he says look
there haven't been nuclear tests he's
not shooting off ballistic missiles he's
not Joe K so I think we've got progress
and and Kim jong-un criticizing Joe
Biden was probably a way to ingratiate
himself to Trump so I'm not going to
antagonize him that I think is the
strategy also we just as Americans find
it repulsive when the president of the
United States agrees with a hostile
foreign leaders criticism of our
politicians even if he's as awful a
politician as Joe Biden
by the way Joe Biden engages in this
kind of stuff too Joe Biden has helped
to launch his campaign by saying that
he's been talking to foreign leaders
about how terrible Trump is and how
Trump is a danger to the world and they
want Joe Biden to run for president
so Joe Biden actually is engaging in
almost this exact sort of thing I guess
it's from the other perspective he's
engaging from it as he's talking to
foreign leaders and he's agreeing with
foreign leaders that Trump is a crazy
awful madman and they want him to run
and Donald Trump is agreeing with a
hostile foreign leader who's saying that
that Joe Biden is an idiot which he is
so they're both kind of engaging in this
but we do find it repugnant we find it
repulsive when the president goes over
there and ever utters the words I agree
with kim jonghwan okay how could he have
done this better what he might have said
is something to the effect of they say
the president Trump do you agree with
Kim jong-un the Joe Biden's an idiot and
he could say something like I don't make
a habit of publicly agreeing with
hostile foreign leaders who criticize
our politicians even when those
criticisms are correct he could have
said something like this where he is
acknowledging the principle of not
agreeing with a guy like Kim jong-un
publicly especially over American
politicians and also admitting that it
is the case that Joe Biden is an idiot
and he has been saying this
years he could have done that except
that it's a little too subtle
that is not Trump Ronald Reagan could
have gotten away with that Ronald Reagan
could have turned a phrase such as that
where he acknowledges the principle he
has a dignified response and then he
gets the dig in at the end he makes a
little joke at the end about how his
opponents an idiot
very Reaganesque Trump doesn't do that
Donald Trump is too blunt Donald Trump
is too personal what we are seeing is
the presidential politics in the era of
reality television when I see Donald
Trump engaging in this kind of behavior
I don't compare that to Ronald Reagan or
Abraham Lincoln that's I think what the
anti-trump right wants to do that's
obviously what the left wingers are
trying to do they're they're trying to
compare these totally anachronistic
historical eras and say see Donald Trump
should have talked like this statesman
or that statesman or this foreign leader
or that person that's not how I see it
what I see is that this is reality TV
it's the kind of personal petty caddy
reality TV stuff when I saw that clip it
reminded me of those old vh1 shows from
the 2000s it reminded me of there is a
show with Flavor Flav called the Flavor
of Love you know where they have the
regular scene is going on and they cut
away and everyone's gossiping and saying
mean things about each other it reminded
me of a classic reality TV show I didn't
let y'all know
invited me a special guest oh hell who
the hell is gonna be nothing is one of
his homies or something
[Music]
in comes is New York from last season
right here this is what we're watching
this is what presidential politics not
just in the United States but around the
world has become
it's just Donald Trump there is flava
flav you say yo I invited a guest yo Kim
jong-un come on in and they come in and
they kind of say nice things about each
other and everyone is scandalized and
everyone is totally shocked and they're
all pretending to be appalled then it
cuts away too you know you'll see Donald
Trump now he'll comment on politics as
though he were a political pundit he'll
comment on politics as though he's doing
a cutaway on a reality TV show so just a
few weeks ago you heard him talk about
Elizabeth Warren he's asked about
Elizabeth Warren he says look frankly I
think she's done for I think she's going
nowhere in this race she's probably
gonna have to drop out cuz she said that
she was an Indian but she's not really
an Indian I could have taken a test I'd
be more Indian than her even though
that's zero hahaha yes sleepy Joe Biden
is doing this crazy Bernie's doing this
it's all reality TV and we love it we
totally love it that's why we love
reality TV Abraham Lincoln is
presidential politics in the era of
great oratory during Lincoln's time one
of the main forms of entertainment was
to go out and listen to politicians give
three-hour speeches literally three-hour
orations and and this was a major
cultural and entertainment event before
Lincoln became president he had the
lincoln-douglas debates he'd go around
the country and it was a road show with
Stephen Douglas and they would debate
the question of slavery in soaring
rhetoric that would go on for hours
Ronald Reagan meant is politics
presidential politics in the era of
Hollywood's golden age in the kind of
final days of glamorous Hollywood so the
Reagan era was highly scripted cinematic
glamorous it wasn't the same thing as
Abraham Lincoln but it was Hollywood it
was epic it was Ronald Reagan going to
Berlin and saying tear down this
Waal mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
going rekt going rather to the Berlin
wall that was politics in the age of
Reagan big-screen President Trump is
presidential politics in the era of
reality television it's smaller it's
Cattier it's more gossipy it's more
focused on personal relationships and
personal intrigue and it's about the
funny barb it's about the the cutting
barb the petty barb it's more authentic
it's move it's not the big screen and
the proper framing and the right shots
it's a camera following you around it's
a tweet
it's an Instagram post it's less guarded
it is less dignified it is less
principled but that's what it is and
it's not Trump's fault I'm not defending
the president exactly on this line of
agreeing that Joe Biden's an idiot with
Kim jong-un I'm not defending the area
of reality television I'm just saying
that's the culture we're in reality TV
didn't get popular in spite of us we
made reality TV popular that's what our
culture wants Donald Trump didn't
accidentally become president we voted
for him we voted for the king of reality
television to be the president that's on
the culture that's what the culture
wants you can't then elect the king of
reality TV to be the president and then
he behaves like he's on reality TV and
then we all pretend that were shocked
and horrified and appalled that he's
behaving like he's on reality TV that's
the culture that we are in and you can
scream and yell and talk about how awful
the culture is that's the reality and
people who are going to succeed in this
culture are going to engage in reality
TV Alexandria Ocasio Cortez has made
herself one of the biggest names in
national politics and because it's the
u.s. therefore global politics and she
does it by making chili
in her crock-pot at night and
live-streaming it and rambling
incoherent lis about global warming she
does it while she's you know painting
her wall or whatever sitting on her
sitting with a
glass of wine on the floor of her
apartment that's reality TV that's not
Reagan that's not Lincoln that's not
great rhetoric that's not cinematic
Hollywood that's where we are President
Trump even explained that this is the
the culture that we're in he tweeted out
quote North Korea fired off some small
weapons which disturbed some of my
people and others but not me I have
confidence that chairman Kim will keep
his promise to me and also smiled when
he called swampman Joe Biden a low IQ
individual and worse perhaps that's
sending me a signal that tweet from from
President Trump is the cut away in the
reality TV show he's explaining what's
happening it's all personal it's all
just about him and Kim it's not about
the principles or the historic
relationship between the u.s. and Korea
he even at the end he says that perhaps
that's sending me a signal oops I don't
know who knows that is the era that
we're in and look either you can whine
and complain about how terrible things
are and how everything was so much
better in the good old days or you can
deal with reality accept it as it is and
look this petty era of politics is
giving us some great stuff such as the
fake per debt presidential campaign of
Eric's whoa well I know he thinks it's a
real presidential campaign it is a
parody of a presidential campaign over
the weekend he sent out a fundraising
email the subject was we're on a
downtrend my heart started beating fast
I said oh no please don't tell me the
swab all campaign is over because Eric's
wall well said I am you therefore I am
Eric's wall well therefore my
presidential campaign is over that's no
good he writes he says quote we're
writing to you with an urgent request we
just looked at our finances it seems
like we're on a downtrend for this
month's fundraising numbers I hope not
because his is my favorite race in 2020
he then posted this video from vice news
where he has asked why America should
elect just another white guy
why should another white guy be
President
well white guy who doesn't see other
identities or understand other
experiences should not be president I do
and you know where there would be gaps
and my knowledge or my experience I will
pass the mic to people
who do have that experience I'm a white
guy and I'm really sorry for that and
I'm terrible and therefore you should
elect me president because I won't ever
be president or say anything or do
anything I'll let other people who are
not white guys do that and that's why
you should elect me a white guy I am you
that's that's Eric SWA Wells
presidential campaign you should elect
me a white guy because white guys are
terrible that's it
he is a parody of a progressive
presidential candidate and in this video
he not only reveals himself to be
vacuous just absolutely that vapid and
empty-headed he also reveals all of the
left-wing slogans that he parrots to be
empty as well so at the end he says I'm
gonna pick a woman for vice president I
pledge to pick a woman why is it gonna
pick a woman because one particular
woman is very talented
no any woman will do any woman I I'm
Eric's wall well and I value women so
much that I think they're all basically
the same and I'm just gonna pick one so
that it makes it easier to elect me a
white guy his slogan is go big be bold
do good what does that mean I have
absolutely no idea what does Eric's well
we'll want to do nobody knows because he
doesn't care because he stands for
nothing because he is the emptiest
candidate in the race but with the
possible exception of beta or work he
says he's willing to pass the mic he
says he's gonna pass the mic for issues
that a white guy shouldn't address if
he's gonna pass the microphone why
should we elect him shouldn't if he's
gonna pass the mic to people who are
better qualified than he is shouldn't we
just elect the person that he's gonna
pass the mic to is he gonna get up there
during the Democrat presidential debates
and they're gonna ask him a question and
he'll say you know before I answer how
about any of the ethnic minorities or
women on stage they should answer okay
then I guess we should elect them too
because we're gonna pass the mic when
Iran fires some missile at one of our
ships in the Middle East is he going to
pass the mic as president SWA well to
someone who knows Iranian culture better
he's gonna pass the mic to someone who
has eaten more falafel and hummus or
something he's a white guy what does he
know about Iran we elect politicians not
pass the mic not to give away their
power to some arbitrary identity group
we elect them for their judgement this
is the same problem bado has bado was in
Iowa he came out and he said he wants
voters to shape him into the
presidential candidate that they want he
wants voters to mold him into the
presidential candidate I guess if you
don't have a spine then you're pretty
malleable you're easily molded we elect
people because they stand for something
if we're just gonna mold you into
whatever we want well why would we ever
elect you why not elect any of the other
people who may be already themselves
align more with what we think and
because they're not infinitely malleable
might actually stand for what they say
they're gonna stand for they might
actually keep their promises that's why
he's not going anywhere
that's why small Wells not going
anywhere I mean these campaigns that
stand for nothing are are collapsing in
real time Joe Biden is afraid of this
we'll get to him a little bit more
tomorrow before we go because it's the
day after Memorial Day we weren't on
yesterday I just want to give a thank
you to everyone who obviously to those
who gave the ultimate sacrifice for our
country and our way of life and our
liberty and also to the families who
have had to make that sacrifice by the
loss of their family members Memorial
Day is one of the strangest holidays
because the way we we commemorate it is
by celebrating and we have backyard
barbecues and we eat hot dogs and we
drink too much and we go out to the
beach and we just have a really nice day
and Memorial Day exists to honor those
who made the ultimate sacrifice who gave
their lives to for for our freedom and I
know a number of gold star families so I
know that Memorial Day for them is not
about beers and burgers and going out to
the beach it's a very difficult day for
them I did a play a few years ago it was
a fundraiser for the USO right here in
Hollywood and it was a play about gold
star families and people who gave their
lives and one of the sort of the central
figure of this play was a guy named
Lance Corporal Corey Ryan Guerin he was
killed in Iraq at the age of 18 signed
up gave his life for our country and for
you and me and for everyone else around
the country and he did it at age 18 and
I got to know his family pretty well
wonderful people Memorial Day is not a
easy day for them it's a really tough
day and so I just want to give a
heartfelt thank you as as we all did
enjoy our day yesterday which and I
guess this is fitting because we get to
enjoy those days because there are
people who are willing to make those
sacrifices for us and to honor their
memory we enjoy ourselves we have a nice
day but I do want to give a heartfelt
thank you to all of the gold star
families the ones who are listening to
this show and everyone else as well and
and a heartfelt thank you to everyone
who gave their life for me and you and
our whole country that's our show
come back tomorrow got a lot more to get
to in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show we'll see
you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show president from slams
Joe Biden by citing the world's worst
dictator it ain't a great strategy
that's today on the bench Shapiro show